sean what's up how we doing i've got a
really difficult family situation
and normally i'm chock full of solutions
but this just has me
at my wit's end and this is the first
time i've ever done something like this
so
i need some outlaw on this uh so i'm
gonna give you the short
abbreviated version and then i guess we
kind of fill in details as we uh as we
need to
so a couple of years ago i found out
uh that my dad is being abused by my mom
okay and it's been going on here i don't
know
physically or psychologically
emotionally psychologically emotionally
nothing nothing physical
they've been married for going on 40
years now
okay and it's been based in a lot of
fear
and paranoia on her end
i grew up with it too i'm an only child
so it was just
me and my dad there and as i was growing
up
i didn't know anything different i
didn't
realize what was going on that it wasn't
normal
but there was just a lot of controlling
on her
and in every little thing imaginable
sure and growing up you know
that kind of i kind of i guess caught
that so to speak and i didn't have many
friends growing up as a result because i
was always trying to control everybody
else
and you know thankfully i've been
because of my wife she's helped me you
know grow out of that
and i see the issue but a few years ago
uh you know my dad when they came to
visit us here we live several states
away
they came to visit and he just unleashed
all these problems that have been going
on
i mean it was just like he could not
hold it back anymore
this is just 30-something years where
he's been treated like a three-year-old
in every little way when you say
unleashed did he just you all just went
out
and had a cigar and he just told you a
bunch of stuff or
he snapped and was yelling in the middle
of the house
no it was it was when my wife and my mom
they went out somewhere
and he and i were just alone together
and then he just
it just kind of like a damn broke and
then all he was just
telling me about all these problems
they've been having he's a
he's a very relaxed guy he's you know
very non-confrontational he's high in
agreeableness uh but he just
you know was saying that they've been
having these massive blow up
fights for several years now i i'm 27
i've been out of the house for you know
about five or six years
but and they never did this growing up
but
you know where they're yelling and
screaming at each other he's going out
in the yard and throwing stuff around
kicking stuff
up so this has been going on for quite
some time but then
over the summer with the whole pandemic
social upheaval it just got to be a
hundred x
uh and as i said before she's
very afraid and very paranoid about
things i mean i remember one time where
she made me get rid of a video game
because she believed that the design on
the cover jacket would
bring demonic forces into the house yes
how was that type of thing oh man wow
and just and just things like that that
you know and me have been building up
resentment
so so fast forward to now how can i help
you
all right so it got 100x like i said and
it got to the point where
again my dad just reached out to me by
text this massive text just profanity
extreme just
telling me about how he can't take it
anymore he's
been at the point where he said that he
just wants to die
he told me a couple months after the
fact that he had a suicide plan
yikes and he almost went through with it
if not for divine intervention i really
believe that he
would have and thankfully now you know
he says that he's not
in that position anymore but he's still
just saying that
you know he'd rather just dive and live
and the
part of the problem right now is that i
know all about this stuff i know about
his psychological state
i know about just how difficult it is
with him but my mom does not know that i
know
and for years i've been living basically
this double existence and
psychologically i just do not know how
to deal with it so
yeah so i think he's at the point where
they need to separate and i just want to
know how to handle this
yeah so i appreciate your heart for your
folks um you're carrying a lot
and after this call i'm gonna ask you to
put almost all the stuff down
okay so a couple of things
that you put out here and we're gonna go
through them systematically
okay um if your dad says i have a plan
then what you're gonna respond with is
you're gonna call
people in his life that love him or
you're gonna call 9-1-1 and you can tell
your dad i love you enough that i'm not
gonna let you kill yourself
i'm not period and unfortunately you're
in a position that
many many many grown kids how old are
you 27
27 how long you been married uh going on
four years now
okay so you're in a in a position
happens
all the time millions millions of people
in the same position
where you suddenly start having to
parent your parents
okay you become the adult in this
relationship
and some of it is your dad is watching
you
in this new relationship he may see
something in between you and your wife
that reminds him of his young marriage
or he may
see something that just makes it is so
beautiful
he realizes he never had that partridge
in a pear tree here's the deal i don't
care what he's seeing
for some reason he feels safe enough to
tell you hey i'm out
i love you i'm out and you have is not
by your hand but in your lap it got
dropped in your lap and you're gonna
deal with it
i will not let my dad kill himself at
least to the best of my ability i'm
gonna call in every calvary i have and
that i know
the second thing is give your dad
permission
to separate from your mom okay and i
don't know if he's asking for that it
sounds like he might be
give him permission dad if you need to
get away get away come stay with us
feel free to come stay with us here's
the thing about your mom
she will never hear it okay i know any
sort of explanation you give to her
she'll never hear
any sort of anything she's not gonna
hear it and so what i'm gonna suggest
is not you feel like you're curing this
psychological burden that you have and
you're living a double life
you're not just stop carrying it okay
you would not
talk just walk up to your mom and start
talking spanish because you know what
you're talking about
this is the same thing so just put that
burden down
right you have a man who loves you a man
who feels vulnerable for whatever
reason you must be a great young man and
you must be doing great things with your
marriage he wouldn't trust you like this
and he's either testing you out like he
has to tell somebody he's crying out for
help
or he's asking for permission and you do
not have my permission to hurt yourself
you do have my permission you can move
into my basement for a season you can
move next door for a season you can
i will still love you if you have to
separate yourself um
in a not safe situation but you're not
gonna kill yourself
and what you need to do at this moment
is to
picture yourself you feel 27 and you
feel like your dad
you need to picture yourself at 45 i'm
standing up tall and i'm going to start
making some of these very clear
decisions
the next thing you need to tell your dad
is you are not allowed to
dump this stuff on me you've got to find
professionals and friends your own age
that are able to handle this stuff
and he may curl up in a ball but he is
you are not his um receptacle his trash
can for
marital issues you're a son does that
make sense
yeah he was working with a psychologist
for a while
and you know he talked he told my mom to
come there but it's
she doesn't see any of this as an issue
so you're i mean you're right i mean
it's you know just all fear
paranoia just for so many years these
tracks have just been worn
down in her mind if i brought any of
this stuff up you know it's not going to
make any difference so you're
you're right about that um so all right
all your dad can do is take care of
himself
right and if he's making suicide plans
um
one of the common misconceptions is that
suicide is the problem
it's not for people who are in his
situation
suicide is a solution and if he feels
like a burden to other people
and he feels like he's gonna hurt and
that hurt is never ever gonna stop
and he's got no one to go to suicide is
a solution to that hurt
right and what you have to do is ring
every bell there is you will not do that
and i would have a hard hard
conversation with him directly
like i am your son and i love you more
than anything in the world except for my
wife
and you are not going to kill yourself
and i'll say oh i
know i'm saying no no no dad you are
not going to kill yourself period
and if i hear about you making a suicide
plan i will call in the calvary i'll
call in 9-1-1 i'll call in every
psychologist i know of in your area
i will ring every bell there is because
i love you too much to let you do that
i would love you to take a break from
mom and come stay with me
i would love you to take a break from
mom come rent an apartment in this
junky apartment complex down the street
from my house you and i will go fishing
and hang out
but i want you to get away from there
and you've got to go see somebody
yeah i've been i talked to him about
two or three weeks ago and that was the
first time i suggested he may have to
leave and it was i thought you know
thinking about that
you know when he told me that he was
taking you know
i forget what the name of the
prescription was but he was taking
double the maximum dosage and three
benadryls and a drink on top of that
just to numb the pain
that's when i came to the solution that
i think this needs to end
well yeah he's just on a dangerous
slippery slope brother
and yeah whatever whatever psychiatrist
is writing
him that type of prescription and
letting him take it in that way
should have their medical license
removed um
but it is what it is well he's doing
more than the maximum dose what he
which he was prescribed so he's yeah but
at some point you run
out halfway before your prescription
should have run out and then they'll
just give you another one
right that's what i'm talking about yeah
he can double up no one can stop him
from doing that but they can stop him
from getting another one
until it's time right and they often
don't
but that's a whole other conversation um
but yeah i think being real direct with
him and letting him know how much you
love him and letting him know that he's
got a place to
land with you um
again when folks can i've got nowhere to
go
and not only do i not have anyone to go
to
but if i do i'm a burden to them because
i guarantee you sean
when he after he left your house he beat
himself up for putting that crap on you
he did he beat himself up he finally had
he finally just let it out
to the one guy he trusts which is the
son and then he beat himself up about it
and that's that
burdensome loop right just piling it on
piling it on he needs to know you're
safe
you got boundaries and you may how about
this
um get with your wife and identify these
boundaries can dad come stay with us for
a month
can dad move into an apartment down the
street
um can i afford to get on a plane ticket
and go
meet with a counselor with my dad can i
do that once do we can we have the money
to do that
um and can i look my dad in the eye over
coffee and say
i'm blessing you and your journey to be
well
you're not doing okay and then you're
gonna deal with mom but you're not going
to
mom's not going to hear any of this
stuff right she needs some professional
help as well
this is a tough one man you're going to
have to lean in
and make real hard grown-up decisions
and have real hard grown-up boundaries
and this is the hardest part you cannot
connect yourself to the outcome
what do i mean by that if your dad does
the unthinkable and hurts himself
takes his life that will not be sean's
fault i'll even go as far as say that
will not be your mom's fault
there will be a cocktail of reasons why
that happened both
way before you even born and and and and
and
if your dad moves in with you and stays
with you for a couple of months
and your marriage gets goofy you and
your wife have to work really hard
you can't hold yourself to the outcome
of this which you can't hold yourself to
is what you can control which is your
attitude
your approach your direction your
boundaries
and your love for both of your parents
that's it man this heart relationships
are hard parenting is
hard and man we will be thinking about
your dad
i want to know how that conversation
goes with your old man so when after you
have that conversation
pause for a minute and then shoot me an
email let me know what you told him let
me know how it goes
and um if he wants to call the show i'd
love to talk to him and if you want to
give me a call back i'd love to talk to
you again sean thank you so much